[Musique]
widy duville bonjour bonjour martinique
1ère bonjour le diamant au jour à la
frp2i alors vous avez 44 ans vous êtes
candidat au diamant le maire sortant
gilbert eustache a décidé de ne pas se
représenter
il vous a désigné comme dauphin vous
êtes l'actuel premier adjoint de la
commune et vous allez mener la liste le
diamant rassembler la nouvelle dilemme
qu'est ce qui vous motive
donc effectivement depuis 2008 je suis
en politique aux côtés du maire actuel
avec une majorité
donc nous avons été reconduit en 2014 et
aujourd'hui les collègues bof m'ont fait
confiance et le 27 janvier dernier
lorsque le maire a annoncé qu'il se
représenterait plus au marché du diamant
donc on a vu toute la population et
effervescente de d'entendre que je
saurai le le le nouveau candidat pour
les élections à venir
à entendre gilbert eustache vous êtes
l'enfant chéri celui qui porte à bout de
bras
en fait c'est peut-être pas gilbert
eustache seulement c'est toute la
population puisque ça fait quand même 44
ans que je vis au diamant donc c'est
toute une population qui m'a vu grandir
c'est une population qui m'a accompagné
depuis mon plus jeune âge et qui m'a
guidé m'empêchant jeudi
de faire des travers comme comme des
jeunes donc je leur doit aujourd'hui
d'être en responsabilité des affaires la
commune qu'est ce qui fait de vous
aujourd'hui un bon candidat
aujourd'hui ce qui fait de moi un bon
candidat c'est que depuis 2008 je suis
restée
je ne vais pas fidèle mais je suis resté
engagez vous à faire de la commune avec
un certain pragmatisme qui qui à petit
ma et aujourd'hui je remplace un
premier adjoint qui est défaillant et
devant
et c'est pas donné à tout le monde de
relever un tel défi je regarde la
martinique est lé premier adjoint se
trouverait dans ma site dans la
situation où je suis actuellement est de
pouvoir s'en sortir un problème adjoint
qui est défaillant vous visez qui vous
visent et hugo tiff tous et on fait du
diamant ya vingt premier adjoint qui a
démissionné donc aujourd'hui j'ai fait
qui a démissionné pour des raisons bien
précises quand même pour liés aux
finances de la commune
je ne pensais pas qu'il n'a pas
démissionné comme ça non non vous savez
tout est prétexte à justifier une
démission donc aujourd'hui démissionner
par rapport aux 10 ans qu'on a
démissionné pas à profit noces et avoir
abrité plusieurs dossiers je dévie
brûlant sur le diamant et ce défi que
j'ai relevé
donc j'avais pas un objectif
qui était axé à l'accession d'un pouvoir
j'avais un seul objectif qui était celui
de sortir le diamant de cette situation
à vous écouter vous somme que vous
faites du go tout c'est votre adversaire
principal
aujourd'hui il ya deux ya deux candidats
en fait nous sommes trois simplement je
respecte une major je respecte une
opposition
ça veut dire que le candidat qui est
dans l'opposition il a était légitime
puisque là une populace la population à
voter jeudi pour cette liste et sinon
nous avons un candidat qui faisait
partie d'un autre majorité c'est comme
vous êtes à l'école comme vous êtes à
l'école vous avez le professeur et les
élèves turbulents doc le le professeur
mais les élèves turbulents au fond de la
classe jacques hugo tous et de l'élève
turbulent
je considère qu'il a été un élève
turbulent et qu'on lui a tapé sur les
doigts
je ne sais pas si on lui a tapé sur les
doigts mais si on la veut rentrer dans
les rangs
simplement non-lieu pas forte que dans
les rangs c'est à dire que lorsque vous
êtes dans une dans une classe dans une
classe et vous voulez faire les bon
travail et donc vous vous écartez les
tubes plus mauvais élèves
oui je peux dire que ces mauvaises mains
parce qu'un de fuir quitter un avion qui
tiennent à vire dans ces circonstances
je pense que la population du diamant
s'en souviendra parce que nous sortons
de loin il a quitté l'as wihr parce
qu'il était en désaccord avec le maire
non est-ce que cela justifie de quitter
le navire
on a été élus la population nous a fait
confiance pas après un programme nous
avons trouvé des difficultés que nous
devrons devrions gérer et aujourd'hui
voilà aussi ce courage
en moi pour avoir mené à bien l'ensemble
des défis qui m'attendent est sans avoir
eu à prendre la première chaloupe et
pour gagner le pont en 20 secondes
la grande priorité de votre programme en
20 secondes je vous savez que j'ai
beaucoup d'ambition pour le diamant donc
la grogne la première aussi bien sur la
construction de l'école de saint charles
donc j'ai reçu les parents d'élèves eux
dernièrement et nous avons accès à ce
que cette école sortent de terre en 2022
il ya le plan lumière aussi puisque la
ville du diamant va se tourner sur
l'écologie donc il y a beaucoup de
dossiers qui sont prêts nous avons aussi
l' annexe de la mairie pour accueillir
la population du diamant à merci
beaucoup monsieur résidus ville merci
bonne journée
merci la martinière
[Musique]